what I want to do in this video is try
to give a reasonable understanding of
the different players involved what that
issue and process your credit cards so
let's start off with the processors the
processors sometimes you could you could
say that the network or the processors
are the people that maintain the credit
card networks and examples of those are
Visa MasterCard master card American
Express Discover and what they do is
they essentially maintain networks of IT
and policies that connect a bunch of
banks together but from just the sake of
this video will do very simple so let's
say that this is network 1
maybe that's visa maybe this right here
is network 2 this right here could be
MasterCard MasterCard and right now the
network's are just circles but you'll
see that they're networks as I build out
this explanation now let's say that I'm
some Bank out there I'm let me call
myself Bank a bank a and I decide that
you know what it would be good for my
business for me to issue a credit card I
could extend credit to my customers
they'll pay me interest maybe I'll make
some fees off of that and I'll it'll be
a good business for my bank so I go up
to let's say visa and I say hey can I be
a member of your network visa has some
policies and if you're I guess a
legitimate bank and you agree to all
those policies you'll become a member of
that network so I've joined that network
and I'm of course not the only person on
that network there's tons of other banks
on that network so that could be Bank B
this could be bank C this could be Bank
D and of course each of these are
network so they all have their own
member banks on them that's mastercards
network right there and so in this
situation they'll come up to let's say
I'm a customer of Bank a they say you
want a credit card and I say sure
that'll be convenient I don't like
carrying cash in my pocket so give me a
credit card and they'll issue a credit
card that looks something like this the
credit card
I think we've all seen credit cards
you'll say Bank a really big up at the
top bank a I'll have a credit card
number that's unique to me my credit
card number my name will be there as I'm
a type of maybe an expiration date and
then here in the bottom right corner
they're going to say what network I'm a
part of in this case it would be visa a
credit card issuer over here would say
MasterCard or if it was American Express
they'd put American Express here and
maybe there's some type of a hologram so
great I have a credit card here I think
we all have a general sense I could use
it and then I'll build a balance and
then in the future I could pay off that
balance to the this bank or I could
carry a balance and they'll charge me
interest which is usually reasonably
high interest so I want to pay it off
fairly quickly but how does this
actually work in the context of a
network so let's say I go to the local
grocery store let me draw that in orange
so let's say I go to some grocery store
over here I'll say g4 grocery and I buy
$100 worth of groceries and I want to
pay with my newly issued credit card let
me write this down this is the issuing
issuer this is the issuing bank I go to
the grocery store I say hey I'd like to
pay with a credit card the grocery store
if they accept credit cards they need to
have some relationship with another Bank
someplace on this visa network in order
for them to accept a Visa card so let's
say that they have a relationship with
Bank B over here this would be the
merchant bank where we could say the
retailer's Bank or it's often in
credit-card lingo called the acquiring
Bank or the acquirer and you might
wonder why is it called the acquire it's
called the acquire because this is the
player that goes out and goes to each of
the merchants and says hey right now you
only accept cash or you only expect
accept American Express wouldn't it be
great if you also accepted Visa or
MasterCard that way you'll have a more
appeal to more customers and you know
every time it'll be more convenient for
your customers and every time a
transaction happens we'll just take a
little bit of a cut of that transaction
and so they go out and acquire different
retailers this was the grocer maybe Bank
B goes off and acquires the shoemaker
May
he goes and he gets the I don't know
gets the tailor on the network these are
all different retailers will now all of
a sudden accept visa because their their
bank their merchant bank is a member of
the visa network likewise it could have
been a member of the MasterCard Network
it doesn't matter this is the processor
and this is their network now this guy X
will would in this context he would
accept Visa so I would give them my Visa
card in the first process is called
authorization authorization
authorization and that's literally to
check whether I'm good for the money
whether this card is valid to buy $100
worth of say groceries so when I swipe
the card or when the grocer swipes the
card is going to send a message to from
that little unit from that point of sale
unit to the acquiring bank that's going
to be forwarded to visa then visa will
say oh that's Bank A's card and we'll
give the number to bank a on their own
proprietary Network then Bank a will
look into their database and says oh
yeah Sal's got a thousand dollars of
credit he hasn't used any of it he is
good for it I authorized the transaction
that message goes back through the
network to Bank B and so then we get
authorized and then the transaction goes
forward and eventually you know as you
could imagine
you can't just authorize the transaction
then I walk away with the groceries at
some point this guy here expects to get
his money back for of giving me the
groceries he expects to get $100 back
and that $100 is going to come from Bank
a but they're not he's not going to get
a complete $100 because obviously each
of these players they're providing a
service this guy he's plugged into the
network and he's offering credit so he's
offering credit he's offering credit the
network operator or the processor is
offering their network and there's other
fee there's other I guess services they
might provide different security
mechanisms if they say hey Sal lives in
Chicago but all of a sudden he's buying
$100 worth of groceries in
in in Saltzburg or someplace you know
that you would that would seems unlikely
then it might send some type of a
warning trigger so people might have
their own security mechanisms but
they're all providing a service this guy
is going out there he might be providing
the actual point-of-sale terminals the
actual network so they're all going to
get a little bit of a cut of things and
so out of the hundred dollars so I got a
hundred dollars worth of groceries
hundred dollars worth of groceries there
will be a two percent and it's not
always two percent I'm just kind of
that's a round number but it also is a
ballpark not completely outlandish
relative to what tends to be the case so
of that hundred dollars of that hundred
dollars that this guy I guess could have
gotten for his groceries he has to pay a
two percent he's got to pay well yeah
let's write it that way
he's got to pay a two percent or in this
case two dollars that's two percent of a
hundred dollars he's got to pay a two
dollar discount discount rate discount
rate to his acquiring bank to acquirer
and you might say gee the aquire that's
great they got two dollars that before
they get two percent of all of these
guys transactions but of course they're
gonna have to share it with these other
people up here and actually the bulk of
it the bulk of it ends up with Bank a so
of this two dollars and I'm doing it in
roundabout numbers Bank a so now we're
going to split up the two dollars Bank a
is going to get let's just say a dollar
seventy and these aren't that far off
from what the real numbers might be and
they change and they depend on the banks
and the network and all of that and the
network's might change their rates one
dollar seventy goes to Bank a so the
issuing bank besides not you know now
that I have a credit balance it'll be
able to charge interest on it it also
got a dollar seventy for that
transaction that dollar seventy of the
two dollars this is called an
interchange fee this right here is an
interchange fee interchange fee
and it generally gets set by the
individual networks although the
networks don't share in that interchange
fee they just say our standard in Jersey
HP is X percent of transactions plus I
don't know 10 cents and then that's what
Bank B is going to pay to bank a so it's
essentially Bank A's cut of the discount
rate of the two dollars this guy is
charging that guy and then the network
and they make their money in several
ways but in general they make money off
of every transaction as well so in this
situation they make roughly about one
thousandth of the transaction or 0.1% so
in this example ten cents of this
discount rate that this guy charged
would go to would go to the processor
would go to the processor or the network
so every time you transact the processor
gets a small fraction of your actual
purchase and then this guy will be left
with 30 well let's see a dollar seventy
$0.10 dollar eighty we're coming from
two dollars this guy's going to be left
with 20 cents so when the whole
transaction gets settled which
essentially means everyone gets the
money they need to get this Bank is
going to send Visa settlement Bank $100
- the dollar seventy that it gets to
keep as part of its interchange fee so
it's going to send visa what is that
that's ninety eight dollars ninety eight
dollars and thirty cents to visa visa
will keep ten cents of it send it to the
acquire so the acquire is going to get
ninety eight dollars and 20 cents and
then the acquire is going to keep twenty
cents for itself and give the retailer
and give the retailer ninety eight
dollars so my numbers aren't exact but I
want to give you the general idea of how
all this works so for the in order for
this retailer to be able to use all of
this infrastructure out there he
essentially had to pay two percent of
the actual transaction that's always not
going to be two percent but it gives you
a nice round figure so this guy benefits
because he gets access to a network it's
convenient for the customers this guy
obviously is getting some type of fee
the more retailers he signs on or the
more retailers he acquires the more cuts
of transactions he's going to make visa
makes a small cut on many many many many
many transit
action so that's where they make their
money and they're obviously you have to
use some of that money to support all of
this infrastructure and then bank a is
going to make that interchange fee which
was the bulk of really that discount
rate that retailer discount rate not
related at all to the federal funds
discount rate and then of course they
they extended credit to me so that
hundred dollars might not be paid
immediately they might be able to charge
me fifteen twenty percent annualised an
annualized percentage rate interest on
that money until I pay it off and of
course I have some type of minimum
balances to pay so hopefully that
explains things a little bit I'll see
you in the next video